thailand's prime minister prayuth chan
ocha has warned that the entire country
could be
consumed by flames if pro-democracy
protests continue to take place
since july protesters have been on the
streets demanding changes to the
constitution
and free and fair elections this despite
legal action
and arrests from the government
[Music]
heading for detention unbowed thai
student activists holding up the
three-fingered salute that symbolizes
their core demands
stop harassment rewrite the constitution
and free and fair elections
emerging later from court they spoke to
reporters
it's been five or six hours that we lost
our freedom
even though we're being released on bail
we all know that we will not be far from
jail
we will be in the jail that obstructs
our freedom oppresses people who come
out calling for democracy
and our future
the government is not giving ground
either thailand's prime minister issued
a warning that growing polarization
could destroy the country
if each side insists on defeating the
other politically our country will
collapse
if that happens just wait and see
everyone will live on a fiery land
consumed by flames if that happens i'm
at a loss for what to do
is a former army chief who led a coup in
2014.
last year he was elected prime minister
in an election critic said was rigged
activists also want to reform thailand's
revered monarchy
that would include overhauling a
draconian royal defamation law
which protects king mahavajira longhorn
anyone insulting the monarch can receive
up to 15 years in prison
the protest movement organizes largely
online
and the government is cracking down
there too it's blocked facebook groups
discussing the monarchy and vows to
expand its dragnet
if they start a new group do anything
illegal
violates the computer crime act we'll
need to act again
this is the system that we adhere to
under the same standard for everyone
we don't just stop halfway we'll keep
doing this no matter how many times it
takes
activists vow they'll hold a major
protest next month
if their demands are not met
so what exactly are the options before
the government for more i'm joined by
thailand's education minister
natha paul tipsuran mr tipsuwan good to
have you on the program
protesters want the government that you
are a part of
to resign so that new elections can be
held will the government resign
at the moment i think the economic
problem
is our major concern if there is a
resonation there's going to be a long
drawn process
that would not move the country forward
i think the countries are
looking at the ways to move forward amid
the
corvette pandemic so i think it's a
better situation if we able to maintain
what we have done
during corvid and continue what we're
trying to improve in terms of
economic situation but then you've been
having near daily protests since july
in thailand are those protests not
something that the government needs to
address
i think once you recognize the
intention of the protest and have the
dialogues with the protesters which i
have
last week last wednesday most of the
concern
on my behalf of the at the ministry of
education
is about education reform the protests
are talking about
um the the new
way of educating students and they want
thailand to improve in our in our
education system so i think it's a
positive
sign that we have the dialogue with them
so we understand
their needs but are you really having a
dialogue of course the protests that you
are referring to were protested by high
school students
it it must be made clear that these
protests were within the wider context
of the pro-democracy protests which
themselves are student-led you keep
saying
that you want to have a dialogue but
then the government
has charged something like 13 people
for sedition and for being connected to
the protests so i'm just wondering what
the message here is for the protesters
on the one hand the government arrests
them
and on the other you are saying that we
want to have dialogue
okay i don't want to comment on
individual cases because
each individual you know act um
with or without respect to the law
you know that's the authority you have
to take in into consideration
and i think they have um you know act
according to each situation differently
but for me as municipal education i've
been aware that number of students are
showing sign you know creating gestures
that showing that this pleasure and i
want to know whether
all these this pleasure about education
or politics and i found out that most of
them are about
educational reform but those educational
reforms again minister are within the
wider context
of the pro-democracy protests and let me
just quote
what you said around eight days back you
said that the right to protest
is part of the democratic process and
the government is willing and ready
to listen to all its citizens it would
appear
you certainly want to talk to the
protesters
but the government doesn't because your
prime minister prayuth
is warning that the country will be
consumed by flames
if these protests carry on so why isn't
the government listening to you
okay i think majority of the protesters
are students and university students
and the prime minister have given
directive to me as
education minister and another minister
who is in charge of
higher education to listen to our
concerns
that are mainly from from students both
university and high school and i think
we have taking that approach and we are
combining all their concerns and i have
to admit on my end
at the ministry of education majority
are
about education not politics
so if you've taken their concerns on
board why are student-led protesters
threatening
another massive protest in september if
the demands are not met
yeah i think we have to understand that
most of the demands
cannot be solved within a week
or month so i think we have to
relay our messages that all their
concerns will be
taken into consideration but whether we
can do or
we can't do will highlight them to the
students
in terms of priority what are the most
urgent issues which are the things that
we have taken
action already because most of the
things that they have talked about
i've addressed in my plan to reform
education
um on monday
ten days ago right right we leave it
there for the time being thank you so
much for joining us
natha paul the team suman thailand's
education minister
okay i appreciate the time thank you